uh let's bring in missouri gop center
josh hawley
on this senator is this neanderthal
thinking because i'm looking by
on the states listing of the states
without mass mandates
missouri's one of them are you do you
have archaic
thinking yeah what a uniter joe biden
is you know this is mr unity and yet if
you disagree with them you're a
neanderthal this guy is also called
people who disagree with them nazis i
mean
it's unbelievable in missouri we're kind
of used to this because we're always
called by the dc crowd
flyover country so we've gotten this
treatment for years
but the truth is there's nothing wrong
with actually following the science and
allowing people to make their own
decisions in missouri we've had a
flexible approach to this from the
beginning i think our governor
has done a good job in giving local
counties the ability to make their own
decisions
but listen if joe biden really wants to
do more why doesn't he focus his coven
relief package on vaccine distribution
yeah and actually put the brunt of the
package there instead he's spending
hundreds of
millions of dollars on stuff like
abortion providers and
environmental justice that shows you
where his priorities spending the
people's money
nine percent only nine percent is going
to covet relief and it's called
the covid relief package when you look
at all the pork and i think we have a
list of so much stuff that lawmakers
have crammed in here
on covety stuff exactly one trillion
dollars though still has not been spent
from past covet 19
relief bills so what does that tell you
does that tell you that this is just an
excuse
they want to say it's a coveted relief
bill but it's just an excuse to get what
they need for their communities and
and they're big donors
yeah it's exactly right it's it's about
their left-wing agenda and actually the
white house has been pretty frank about
this i think they called it the most
progressive piece of domestic
legislation
in a generation and that's about right
notice covett is nowhere in that
sentence
i mean you look at their priorities
funding abortion providers funding
environmental justice shoveling monies
to blue
money to blue states whose revenues are
actually
up i mean it's just pure politics
meanwhile what about workers
you know all of their promises to
workers about direct relief they've
scaled those back and scaled those back
so workers are getting less vaccine
distribution is actually getting less i
mean not as you said less than nine
percent of the money
actually going to medical covered relief
and all the rest of it
to their special interests into their
left wing agenda it's crazy
yeah uh we know a lot of people watching
right now they are looking at that 1.9
trillion dollars and they're thinking
okay but where's my check you know there
are a lot of
people senator in this country who are
hurt and bad
and it is great that the federal
government can open up our wallet
their wallet uncle sam's wallet and and
write them a check to help them through
this tough time
the problem republicans have is with all
that other stuff
right yeah that's exactly right i mean
listen
i've supported direct relief to working
families for months on end and the fact
it
got it in the last coveted relief
package back in december
that president trump signed i thought it
should have been even more back then the
president was right about that
he wanted two thousand dollar payments
that's exactly what it should have been
uh and so this i am all for that the
problem is is that the
the rest of this bill while they've been
scaling back the democrats have relief
to working families
they've been loading up their other
special interest priorities i mean 50
million dollars for abortion providers
why is that in a coveted bill what does
that have to do with covet
environmentalist
left-wing causes getting millions and
millions in this bill
and that's just the stuff we know about
wait till they read it today
sure and what about 350 billion dollars
to states and local governments
that shut everything down whereas uh
other states like uh florida kept things
open they've got a lower unemployment
rate the states that have a
high unemployment rate like new york
where we're sitting they will benefit
from this
absolutely they will and the thing about
it is is that many of those blue states
that are going to get
billions under this bill their tax
revenues are actually
up in 2020. i mean they ended up doing
better than they thought that they than
they were going to
and as you say they've already gotten
billions in previous packages so this is
a it is a left-wing giveaway
it is a left-wing social agenda that
they're trying to use here and they're
going to do it all right without
republican support i mean they're not
even attempting
to get republican votes in the senate so
the good news is they threw out nancy
basically symbolic throughout nancy
pelosi's transit system
and throughout chuck schumer's bridge to
canada
but you and you have more targeted
relief that
moderate so-called moderate democrats
are asking for so that'll be in the bill
i thought it's kind of interesting is
senator ron johnson is making uh
somebody read the whole bill out loud
that's going to delay any
passage it's 600 pages but let's move on
and talk about some of the
president's nominees that are getting
some turbulence one of which is a very
controversial pick xavier becerra
the attorney general of of california
one of the controversial quotes that i
want to share with you that you know
about
april 3rd there are not criminals they
haven't committed a crime
against someone and they are not acting
violently or in a way that's harmful to
people
and i would argue they are not harming
people indirectly either if you call
them criminals it's a lot easier to get
people to turn against them
than if you call them undocumented
immigrants
that's how he's going to approach the
border that's who he's going to approach
his job
if he gets the job at hhs
yeah you know this is listen i mean
border illegal border entry in this
country is a crime
and what's interesting is when i asked
merrick garland the attorney general
nominee if he
supported keeping illegal injuries he
wouldn't answer me
yeah so you see what you see a pattern
here from the bite administration which
is that
they're going to turn a blind eye to
what's going on at the border we already
have another crisis building at the
border they know it by the way
and yet they're doing nothing so they're
going to illegal immigration
doors are gonna be open and becerra i
mean this is a guy who has tried to
criminalize
pro-life advocacy in his own state i
mean what's his priority been it's been
going after
folks who are pro-life it has been
pushing a hard
left
yeah i think he is in trouble and uh you
know that's good news because this is a
guy with a
radical radical left wing record and so
i hope that the senate democrats take a
hard look at this and say is this really
the kind of guy i mean a guy
who wants to prosecute pro-life
advocates a guy who is in favor of
partial birth abortion
wants to use taxpayer money to fund
abortions
i mean again that's just that's radical
well particularly during
a global pandemic when joe biden's
number one priority is getting rid of
the pandemic you would think that they
would have
a somebody from the healthcare world or
somebody who is a doctor to
head that up but instead they've got the
former attorney general
senator wanted to ask you about your
office is up on the
capitol hill complex and the house has
canceled today's votes
because of worries and the headline out
of the washington post is
capital police intel shows militia group
plotting to take the capital today
because march
4th historically has been inauguration
day
before the 20th amendment what do you
know
about this threat and how seriously are
people taking it
you know i don't i only know what i've
what i've read and what i see reported
so i i personally haven't been briefed
i'm not aware of any briefing that's
been offered
to senators at large about this uh you
know we're planning to be in session
today
and to go about our work and i'll just
say that you know we've got a
if there are serious threats then
obviously we hope that those will be
reported
uh to uh members and we'll be able to
make a decision but in the meantime
we've got to keep doing
the work that we were sent here to do
and do it as safely and reasonably as we
can
do you think that the national guards do
you still want them there michael waltz
was on with us earlier congressman waltz
and
he said it's time for them to go home
oh i mean i think the fact that we've
got thousands of national guardsmen and
women
and you know i certainly appreciate
their service but the idea that they're
just going to be there indefinitely and
that appears to be the plan you know
we've had these hearings
up on the hill recently about january
6th and folks have been asking over and
over how long will the guard
be on capitol hill nobody can get an
answer i mean it appears to be
indefinite i think the idea of keeping
them there indefinitely
and keeping a barbed wire fence around
the capitol indefinitely
is crazy i mean this is the people's
house it should be open to the people
and just to say that you know hey maybe
for for ever
we'll have the massive guard presence uh
and have it fenced off from the public i
think is the wrong choice
senator what is life like for you now uh
with uh
backlash from democrats in particular
about uh
about your uh would-be speech on january
6
and the unrest that we all know about
have things settled down for you
you know it has been uh truly it has
been amazing to see the outpouring of
support
since their efforts to cancel me to
cancel other conservatives to cancel
anybody
who won't go along with their radical
left agenda of course they lied
every which way about my objection on
january 6. they lied about my positions
and it hasn't worked i mean that's the
that's the great thing you look at my
support in my home state of missouri you
look at the support we've gotten from
around the nation they have
it's utterly failed and backfired
actually and i think people want folks
who are going to stand up and tell the
truth
and who no matter what the criticism is
are going to keep on doing their job and
that's exactly what i'm going to do
all right well we certainly want
everybody safe today as they do their
job up on the capitol
hill complex sir thank you very much for
joining us today
thank you thank you